yourself a feminist yes no and then why
and I'd say no
I'm not a feminist because
I think I believe
I'm in between I would say but I'll say
no because I don't think
there's things that men can do and
there's things that women can't do and
there's things that women can do and
there's things that men can't do if that
makes sense so I thought that's why
I'm in the middle and I'm still seeing a
bit of neh I'm not a feminist
um yeah me I'm I'm similar to Janae
um I don't think I'm a feminist because
I do believe that I am like strong on
like gender roles
um so I do believe that um there's
certain things that a woman should do in
a relationship there's certain things
that managed to do in a relationship but
I'm also like big on women empowerment I
just don't feel like it collides yeah
okay go ahead I would say no
um I don't really identify with anything
that feminism stands for anymore
okay go ahead
um yeah I'm sort of like in between I I
would say I'm very much a traditional
feminist
um not so much a modern feminist
um I still have those Traditional Values
and I feel like I do believe in female
empowerment I do believe in the movement
of feminism
um yeah
okay go ahead yeah I would say I'm sort
of in between as well
but it just gets a bit too technical I
believe in them obviously opening doors
for women but it gets too technical for
me so for me I'm in between as well this
feminists role
I do not consider myself to be a
feminist whatsoever a man and a woman
has complete different duties and roles
they're not equal a man's purpose is to
protect provide hunt and lead and a
woman's purpose is to nurture and
reproduce as far as I'm concerned they
are not equal
I'm not a feminist I'm very in tune with
myself spiritually
and I feel like everything in the modern
day world just really collides with my
spirit so definitely not wow a whole
room not one feminist wow why do you
guys think that is where has it gone too
far
my scarcity is promoted I think that's
too far I think
for women having multiple sexual
partners is really bad for your mental
health
um it messes up your hormones
biologically
and also like even if you're not
technically sleeping with all of them
what kind of person are you if you're
just an object on millions of people's
screens and all that object is is
your boobs and bum they're not really
seeing you for who you are and if you
don't care about who you are enough to
put that out there and all you want to
put out there is your body and then I
think that shows that maybe there's
something not quite right inside that
maybe you don't value in yourself so you
only value the exterior part of yourself
do you guys know women that can sleep
around and are genuinely happy doing it
no I don't think I've ever met one
really no
no one no so why do you think it's
pushed so much if the outcomes aren't
good for women
because I feel like people
like people that maybe
um this is just like from me watching
but I feel like people that maybe do
sleep around a lot
um maybe if they don't actually like
know who they are or like know what they
stand for completely and they want to
act like they're happy so they'll tell
people yeah this is what makes me happy
this is what I do so you do it too so
it's like it's like some whole gang
thing
um like even Amber Rose for example this
what is that thing she does a nude
walks yeah that's that walk without it
okay would anyone go to a walk
anyone here no okay okay yeah I'll go no
I can't lie I would go for fun like to
watch it I would do interviews like yeah
I don't think I would take part in a
sock walk no yeah definitely no I don't
think so but yeah what I was going to
say about the Amber Rose
um top walk I feel like with feminism
now it's if you show your the more body
you show the more empowered you are as a
woman and I feel like there's so much
more to that and it's like they try and
talk for all women as a whole when
really this is your opinion so even in
dating now it's like men they'll come
and talk to you in a certain way like
you're a feminist already like they just
think you're a feminist I don't know I
don't say explain it but yeah do you
think older women sabotage younger women
yeah yeah
yeah I I feel like going back to what we
were just talking about as well like I
feel like women are trying to compete
with men and I think that is literally
where the problem is we are trying to
compete with men why is it okay for a
man to sleep with loads of women but
it's not okay for me and actually do we
actually enjoy that like we have to
actually ask so ask ourselves like do we
actually enjoy
casually giving our body like that and
you know because we have emotions and we
you know we feel things and like for men
it's different they can go and do that
and have zero emotion whereas with women
it's completely different and we can't
you know deny that so is it though like
do you actually think like do you
actually well most of my friends I feel
like you know they tell me stories and
they sleep with someone and they get
attached like so you don't think men do
or do you think they're just better
hiding their emotions because they don't
no they don't they don't think so no I I
meant to go and do that and have zero
emotion they can do that and and they're
programmed to be like that whereas why
are we trying to compete with that but
but just because someone's programmed to
be like something I don't feel like
they're being completely open and saying
like they can just go and sleep around
with anyone and they don't feel any like
I don't believe that I actually don't I
don't think they've got to the root of
the problem of why they can't do that
because that's not Humane but the thing
is like when money is money power and
Status they do do it so it's like yeah
it's a trend for a month is Chris Brown
like saying stops no
of course they're loving it but I feel
like there's effects that is just it's
not attached to okay you're sleeping
with loads of people this is why you
feel like that I thought they might feel
type of ways but they're not attaching
it to all because I'm just going around
seating with loads of women because I've
got loads of male friends and I see the
after effect that it has with them
sleeping with loads of women but they
weren't actually admit yeah they would
actually admit it or pinpoint it on that
but I think that sort of goes back uh
that sort of goes back to like the whole
peer pressure with men and maintaining
this image of like you know when you
become successful and you have money
those girls come with it and I feel like
a lot of men are trying to force that
and that's probably why your friends are
feeling some type of way afterwards
because they're doing something but
maybe they don't really want to be doing
it but also I'll be real like
when men obviously sleep around their
body's not going to change if a woman
sleeps around your body's a temper your
body is going to change it's going to
adapt to whoever you're sleeping with so
that's where you know I mean I'm saying
like Okay the levels of women and men
financially are like the same but
like Following being full of fashion
like it's like
you're the mean like you're lowering
your standards and your body changes
that women we're very we're all adapt to
a man well not me but you know what I'm
saying as for men they just you know I
mean they can go around do what they do
in hunky dory their body's not going to
change a woman's body does change you
know what I mean you're a key so yeah
very true yeah very true and I feel like
as women we we just have a lot more to
lose and that there's a lot more at
stake for us so that's why we are
naturally gonna be very you know picky
and selective and
you know I I pride myself in being
selective and you know not giving my
body freely to just as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible